to have people look at you
a certain type of way because of
something that i can't help and i don't
want to help it because
i love my melanin and i love being a
black girl i love being black
but it just sucks that sometimes people
will treat you
and will look at you a certain type of
way and
you haven't even given me an opportunity
to get to know me
i've been walking for hours under the
sun
but if our ancestors did it for us and
then so much more how can i not
amara i've been looking forward to this
conversation
for a few days now and we're not going
to talk about your music
so much we're really going to talk about
how you're using your artistry
and the platform that it's giving you to
change the world
you know that you can affect
and honestly i really commend you for
all the work you've been doing and how
you've been using your voice
you've been really courageous and bold
in this space
this summer specifically you were very
hands-on when it comes to the black
lives matter movement
you were on the front lines of the
protest why was it so important for you
to be
there not at home watching not posting
on social media but
on the front line first of all thank you
so much for um
you know allowing me to use your
platform to continue my work as an
activist and
to continue to bring awareness and
everything else i am a black woman in
america
i am an afro latina in america i am a
latina in america
in this case you know it just meant a
lot to me i don't like people that talk
and do nothing they just talk so in my
case i wanted to talk and be about it
i'm really about the things that i say i
don't do this for clout
i don't do this for promo i do this
because i actually care
and one of the reasons why i care the
most not only because of my generation
and the world that we live in now for my
own people
but my children i don't have any
children
but the day that i do my children will
be black like me
and i don't want to live in a world
where i have to be fearful of
having kids because i'm afraid what's
going to happen to them so i just feel
like it's my duty to be part
and you've also urged the latinx
community to show up as well
i want to get your perspective as an
afro latina
why do you think it's so necessary in
this moment for the latinx community in
the black community to unite
well because to a certain extent the
latin x is just as
black as the black community whether
they want to admit it or not
i know that there's a lot of people and
i and i try not to get upset even though
that i'm only but human
but i try to understand that it's more
the lack of knowledge
is the lack of education that makes
people
act the way that they do you know the
lack of education and knowledge of your
own history
doesn't allow them to understand that
yes you may be
puerto rican you may be dominicana
colombian honduras
cuban you may be all those things but
also no one understand
that if you go back into your history
into your race into your roots
we were there we were there you know you
got some of us
you know you got some of this african
ancestor in your dna as well
so you know i just think it's important
because we are minorities especially in
this country
we are minorities in this country in my
case i feel like i have the best of both
worlds you know
in a country where immigrations and
immigrants is such a big topic
as latinos and then on top of that
blacks is a big topic and then i'm right
in the middle it's like you get
both of the headaches you get both of
those perspectives
so it is important for us to unite and
just
even if we take away the race aspect of
it just
as humans just knowing what's right and
what's wrong because we
know it doesn't matter where you're from
we know when they're treating you bad we
know when something is unfair
we know when something is not when
there's no justice we know what it is
so it's like yes as the black community
and the latino or latinx community need
to unite but overall
it's just about doing the right thing
besides the knowledge and the lack of
knowledge
why do you think there is resistance
when it comes to some
in the latinx community associating
themselves with the black community
what's what's the issue there
well we can't expect things to change
overnight we have to understand this is
a generational
you know brainwash you know what i'm
saying this has happened from one
generation to the other
to the other to the other then it passes
on to your mom and then your mom and
your dad teaches you the same thing
so you kind of become on the defense
mode all the time
until you get a book and actually read
watch documentaries
do your own research you're never gonna
understand
where this originated from it's really
new news to me
that the afro-latino community
is separated from the latin community
the latinx community
and also that the latinx community some
not all
don't really feel like they need to
unite with the black community it's new
because i've always thought that we were
in this together
yeah you're right we can't generalize
and we're not generalizing
there's good people like there's bad
people there's people that support these
people that don't so we're not
generalizing
but it is true within the latin
community we
are somewhat within the latin community
those that are of darker complexion
those that have a higher top you know
higher melanin
we are looked at differently we are
treated
somewhat differently it's like oh there
goes that black person
or for example things that i heard
growing up that made me feel terrible
when i was growing up sometimes
i used to hang out with some friends in
like elementary middle school and things
that i remember very clearly
and i remember seeing their parents say
i don't want you hanging out with that
black girl i don't want to run them
black kids
it made me feel and i would ask my mom
all the time like did i do something
wrong
i am not doing this right now because
sometimes i get i'll be getting
emotional
but then i would ask myself did i do
something wrong like
why am i seen i am not doing this right
now
but this is why i commend you so much
because you know this you have people in
your comments i've seen them
come to you and talk about how much you
are helping them because you're not
alone in that
it sucks and it feels terrible to
have people look at you a certain type
of way
because of something that i can't help
and i don't want to help it because
i love my melanin and i love being a
black girl i love being black
but it just sucks that sometimes people
will treat you and will look at you
a certain type of way and you haven't
even given me an opportunity to get
to know me i'm like a really nice person
i'm a really good girl but
you don't want your kids hanging out
with me because
my skin is dark you know i can't help
that and i don't mean to help it
and i know that there's so many little
girls that look up to me
and feel the same way that i felt you
know or i
i used to like date um like you know you
know i mean i did anything i you know i
believe in love and you could love
whoever it is that you want to but
i remember dating you know this
light-skinned latino and
his mom was like when i went to his
house his mom was like
like this is what you brought like this
is who you're dating
like oh so now you're dating black and
it's just so
terrible because it's like what world do
we live
in you know that's why i'm concerned my
question for you is
i'm sorry no no and i'm sorry that
it brought you to tears but i i honestly
this is necessary because at this point
as an adult you're able to look back at
those situations and say okay those
people were just ignorant
honestly i probably shouldn't have been
messing with them in the first place
because
right just not vibing where i'm vibing
but
as a kid you don't have that
understanding yet so
in those moments how did you deal with
it or what did your mom say
to make you keep going and have the
confidence you have today
because amara no matter what people have
told you in the past you're shining now
and you're able to show up as you so
where did that come from
my mom was always very supportive of me
and i guess it also
my mom's a little bit lighter than me
and my mom's sisters and family members
are lighter
but on my father's side they're very
very melanated they're very dark-skinned
and um my mom always told me growing up
you know because of the color of your
skin
you're going to learn this later on in
life but you're always going to have to
work twice as hard
and she always makes sure to you know be
there to tell me you're beautiful
your hair is pretty you have a nice she
was always there to make me feel like i
was a queen
and sometimes i believe that parents
don't know how powerful the words are
you know as children we look up to you
guys everything that we know is because
you guys teach us
so when you let us know that we're
beautiful that we're amazing that we're
smart that we're powerful
we can do anything when we go out to the
world
we feel confident because we feel like i
don't care what you tell me because my
mom told me
that i am blah blah blah so she always
made sure to
you know that i knew that i was a strong
black beautiful little girl and i'm
grateful for that because that helped me
survive a lot of terrible situations
it's like the world is so full of
culture of diversity of race of
food sounds rhythm body shapes just
features the world is filled up so much
and we're consistently just fed this
little bit
so i don't know i just pray that we're
able to continue to grow
i pray that this is only but the
beginning of many great things to come
i am grateful that we are progressing
even if it's little
and slowly but the progress is coming i
am proud
and honored to know that i have been
able to inspire motivate
um others to stand up as well and i am
excited
to see what the future holds well i'm
excited about your new
documentary with the documentary that
you're in hbo
have a now documentary which seems very
enlightening can you talk to us about
the experience of shooting that and what
topics you covered in your interview
with
director alberto fieras it was great i
think it was great it was amazing
because i was able to
one i'm always grateful to every single
platform that allows me to continue my
activism
and just bring awareness i'm so grateful
every single time so just thank you
alone but
being able to share this documentary
with so many different people that have
lived so many different experiences
in the latin community it was a really
nice experience it was great to hear you
know some of them were talking about the
immigration some of them were talking
about
um the you know the the reasons and the
necessity of why we should vote
um in my case i'm talking about colorism
and the issues that happened in our
community and
we had native americans and we just had
a little bit of everything like
i felt like this is such an amazing and
powerful documentary because
it really shows you what we're about
you know so i think it was great um like
i said you guys cannot miss you have to
go check it out it's
bomb is amazing i was honored to be able
to be with so many
powerful talented people so i can't wait
for you guys to check it out